my biggest spurts of growth came through
community
and my biggest downfalls have come
through community so when i was a little
kid i would be hanging around with
people that were doing drugs selling
drugs fighting stealing breaking into
homes so guess what i was doing the
pattern
is actually the thing that's taking life
away from me every time this guy opens
his mouth i'm like
damn
oh my goodness
yeah i didn't know you were gonna click
that thing for us to go live
well you you manifested it man you
clicked it and here we are let's do it
so so garen uh garen's been a long time
friend of the channel and uh he's been
on youtube my channel a couple times and
i met him recently in arizona he's part
of genius network that was how was that
first session for you man it was so
weird because
we've connected we've spoken it was like
facetime it was like i was being
interviewed by you
and then meeting you in the first time
it was like i knew you for a long time
but i was like oh yeah we haven't met in
person but honestly the genius network
was really awesome because a lot of
people doing big things in the world and
everybody was just there to share and
being a witness to other people sharing
so i loved it
what
time made you want to
not even just join genius what made you
want to join another group of
entrepreneurs or even give it a shot
you know
some some of the biggest uh
my biggest spurts of growth came through
community
and my biggest downfalls
have come through community like
whatever community i was hanging around
the most
i tend to do what they do
so when i was a little kid i would be
hanging around with people that were
doing drugs selling drugs fighting
stealing breaking into homes
so guess what i was doing
selling drugs i never did drugs but i
sold drugs fighting stealing and i did
very well
so
once i found health and wellness
community i started doing what they were
doing personal development
transformation learning about emotional
intelligence and eating well lost 35
pounds put on 19 pounds of muscle and 10
years later at age 42 years young i'm
still thriving strong then
i got in groups of
high thriving community people that are
building productivity building
generational wealth building themselves
up
and every group that i associate myself
with and lean in i tend to do what they
do
so this new community where i just met
you genius network
there are people that are doing
in in different areas i wouldn't say way
more than what i'm doing because when it
comes to the heart and energy
let's go there with the best of them but
as far as like business like you with
the youtube i barely have any youtubes
and
you know like
there's so many people that are doing
certain things that i
i'm interested in at levels that are
they're pre-calculus and i'm abc's but
if i associate myself
with this group i tend to do
what they do
if not better or at least i'm playing in
the same energy or frequency
so every time i go and that was the
first time i've been in person in a
while every time i go i end up coming
away feeling just with higher standards
like man i am
i'm doing great and
i got to be playing at a at a higher
level you know we gotta we there's so
much more that i'm capable of doing and
being around high level entrepreneurs is
always kind of reinforces that what was
your biggest takeaway from the group
honestly man there was there was
there were two things
it was something you said which i'll
tell you last
and then there was something that is
that guy nick what's nick stevenson or
something like that
the bitcoin guy yeah yeah yeah i know
nick says people are always trying to
focus on bettering their best
and i've even tried to do that i was
like i'm gonna outdo myself but i'm
gonna do my he was like man that's so
hard
but if you better your worst if you look
at areas in your life
and you become a little bit better
in the worst areas
you make everything else better and i
was like yo that's actually more
feasible in my mind
and it just it blew me away of how
i can look at areas of my life where
let's say youtube this is where you come
into play let's go
my most strong
my most strongest feature when it comes
to serving humans
number one is in person yeah nick
peterson i knew it wasn't stevenson but
it's like you planted it in my head i
couldn't think of what it was so nick
my most strongest asset when it comes to
connecting with humans one is in person
in person like i have a retreat coming
up the weekend of june 10th called the
awaken the artist within retreat that is
it's literally almost sold out but that
right there being a retreat space out
it's it's a whole different dimension
whole different planet
but me on video
me on podcast me and commercials but me
on video is a strong asset i
don't have any assets really
strong of my own putting out my own
video content it's on your station on
impact theory and all these other
stations and when you were like he was
like dude
just do like just do it and it's not
what you said
it's how easy you made it sound
and the last time someone said ben it's
just work you're gonna work anyways last
time someone said it like that i ended
up
earning 15 million dollars over the next
what nine years in that company so
um
but and that was early on but when you
said he's like just do it and
it's it was the youtube it's the whole
youtube conversation he's like don't
worry about editing don't worry about
color correcting don't worry about all
these different things which stops me
because i'm a creative and anytime i do
things where i'm focused on
nine million other things than being in
my genius i stop and i don't want to do
it because it's too difficult
you like so don't focus on any of that
just pull your camera out and just do it
and i was like
i cannot
come back
with anything smart
to be doing it i can't rebuttal that
so that was one of the biggest things
that really really really hit me not get
caught in the weeds being my genius and
then just you just learn over time and
then you hire people to do the things
that you don't want to get into the
weeds about
it sounds like we're cooking on a garen
jones youtube channel guys
yeah some something's and i already have
since we spoke i have six videos and one
of them is going out today so like
i just pulled my phone out and i just
went in
i love it man also the coaching right
and we talked about turning your
coaching videos into youtube videos too
you had a great when you went live
i think it was even that day
you were in arizona and you went live
and i saw a couple of your coach that
you're talking to the slingshot
uh i forget the guy came on and it was
just like felt down and now didn't know
what to do and how this stuff happened
to him and you're like you know what
like it's a slingshot just the further
back you go the faster you can shoot
forward
um
like all those are videos for your
channel
yeah and that was another it was that
was huge for me because i was like you
know what what he was like what are you
selling i was like well i do retreats i
do group coaching i do one-on-one
coaching
but i don't have any of that online it's
just like me talking saying some slick
stuff and things like that but if
anybody
saw how i worked with people how i
process people how when somebody is
going through something really deep
traumatic and how i can allow myself to
be accessed and channeled to be a safe
space to live then put the puzzle pieces
together in their nervous system and
then walk them back to where they
currently are safely and make them feel
absolutely well they make themselves
feel absolutely amazing and and and just
i feel like i have so much faith in
myself and so much passion i know what i
want to do i have so much clarity in my
life and i have action steps
i when i'm around people and i do that
but i don't have anything online
that sees me in that so if people saw
the value
i would actually make more than six
figures a year
for one-on-ones in 12 coaching sessions
because they would see the value and
what would happen into their life
uh joe polish who runs genius network
likes the he has a term called return on
genius so like for the investment that
you make in the group what's that what's
the return to get out of it and it's
great when it can be quantified it's
like hey you know that being part of
that group costs 25k to be in the room
and already from like first meeting
already getting 100k plus idea on what
you can do just shows the value of
joining groups and being around people
who can help elevate your thinking on
things that they're great at and maybe a
blind spot for you i love leading with
like what are you selling so we can tie
in what you're selling to help you get
more sales and i think for you as good
as you are talking to camera
i think you're even better talking to
humans
yeah
right
and and if we just filmed that and you
already are filming it right i mean
that's the thing with your instagram
lives you're already filming it you're
already doing coaching
now just make that into a youtube video
so it's not just like you have these if
you guys don't know gary you go follow
him on on instagram he does these
coaching sessions and uh he just goes
and riffs and then brings random people
up it's not like it's all staged and
they know who's going to come on and
says hey how can i help you and then
they they go off talking together
and the problem there is it's like it's
great experience whoever's live but then
it
kind of dies afterwards because nobody's
going back on somebody's instagram lives
and seeing what they were doing
but if that was cut into a youtube video
then that lives forever in in the stuff
that you talk about is is evergreen
stuff that people will still need in two
years and five years and 10 years right
it's not just like a strategy for right
now um so yeah i mean even just going
back and cutting all those videos
because they're still there you save
them
into youtube videos and you start
getting a lot more
i mean yes a lot more business but even
more it's like a lot more impact like
how many people can relate to
the people who are
being coached by you it's like man
that's me
now we get to spread that to youtube in
the world even the other day when i was
talking to somebody that
they were they're business driven so
they got a really successful business
but inside they've always wanted to be a
singer they wanted to be some kind of
artist they wanted to be uh publicly
speak but they don't have the confidence
to do it so they overcompensated their
business to hide
away from the thing that they really
want to bring out their authentic
expression so i'm having a coaching call
with this person
and i said you know what i'm actually
hosting a three-day
retreat the weekend of june 10th
called awaken the artist within i think
you would be perfect for it
and then they registered that night but
there were other people that were on the
live one was like no i need that for me
so i ended up from that live
registering
six people um from a high ticket retreat
that's literally almost sold out and i
haven't even posted on it publicly
and that's from you know a couple
hundred people a couple thousand people
you know ending up watching that live
now imagine
40 000 people 100 000 people you know
watch it on youtube
yeah you got me again bro it just keeps
going
every time every time this guy opens his
mouth i'm like damn it's almost like a
big brother even though i'm probably
older than him yeah how do you
i'm cool i'm 42 on the 20th so we're
we're right there okay yeah we're both
we're both okay you're 41 on 42. i'll be
43 in july so we're yeah so it's like my
big little big brother and every time he
says something i'm like
here's what's beautiful though and
that's what i love about evan
evan is smart
evan is successful
evan impacts lots of people
but evan's not he's not
too high on himself to not learn
so when i when i met him
he gave he gave me the opportunity to
share something with him
that allows him to grow and this is how
whenever you can like really
hold yourself to the standard and then
be not not not be too big to like learn
from somebody evan gave me the
opportunity to even share some stuff and
i won't i won't put his stuff out there
unless he wanted to but he gave me the
opportunity to share my expertise in a
way in which he can also level up as
well and if there's anybody out there
find you good people that
that
you can share
and be honest and vulnerable with
in a moment that will allow you to level
up in your own life and this is
something i love keeping great people in
my life so i just want to acknowledge
you evan for you're like this
highlighted person and everybody's like
evan evan evan evan evan you came to me
and you're like listen i have something
to i'd love to share and i'm like wide
open baby let's go yeah i'm happy to
share and i love kind of pulling back
the curtains so people can see
what goes into it that we're all just
trying to figure things out and that i
think a lot of times if the if the
expert comes off as kind of too perfect
then you can't relate so i love being
able to share the story but um we so
inside genius network we had a uh
there's a little hot seat moment
where you group up i think we had three
or four people um
i hear garen yell carmichael
from the back of the room it's like okay
we're gonna we're doing this it's going
down and uh and and we kind of ran out
of time before i got my chance to share
my thing and so uh i asked aaron hey man
i got something that i think you you'd
be uniquely qualified to help me with
i'd love to pick your brain at some
point over the next two days it was a
two-day event and uh and then i think
like at the next break i just came
downstairs and found you and for me it
was
uh a lot of the stuff that we do is so
goal-oriented and focused and where
you're going to be in two years and a
lot of the tools we're going through are
also kind of
planning like that and um i i wanted to
go the opposite way and just trust that
good things happen to me that great
things happen to me and how do i open
myself up more to that and i thought you
know what if there's one spiritual
badass in this room who can answer that
question
it's karen jones we got to find that man
uh yeah and then you gave me you gave me
some great advice and it's also the
willingness to ask for help you know
like if you find somebody who
you think might be able to help having
the courage to go up and say hey
i've got a question
i think you might be able to give me
perspective
um and maybe they shut you down but at
least you gave your shot and
you'd be surprised by how often people
would give you a couple minutes and
maybe in those couple minutes something
unlocks you know i remember like for
yours you came in asking about um
being intentional with time and then the
first person was like giving you all
this advice on how to schedule and how
to do all this stuff and i asked you
like hey dude is that what you even want
man like you're
you're this creative genius he's like
yeah having schedules and rigidity feels
like i'm in prison right it's like
exactly you gotta you gotta do your
thing and so sometimes it's easier to
kind of see it from the outside somebody
give you perspective to say hey if you
just tweak this little mindset shift
right here it can make all the
difference in the world
yeah man
and i appreciated that too because i'm
not i'm an implementer so as soon as i
have awareness assumption i'm already
i'm like man the results already showed
up because it's
i embody the lesson instead of be like
oh yeah i got it and do nothing with it
so i appreciate you for taking the time
so listen here's another question one of
the one of the guys in the group has
this term called strategic byproduct and
the idea is
you're working on something
and then something else just pops up as
a result of it i like to call it karmic
byproduct because it's not you're not
strategic about it you don't know what's
going to come out of it but by being
involved and investing yourself and
asking questions and working on
something
other doors will happen and open for you
but by sitting on the couch it never
happens so often we go in as thinking
for something asking for something we
get
something completely different that ends
up being way better so out of the past
week what was what's a karmic byproduct
for you or maybe you went in thinking
it's going to be this but i ended up
getting something way better yeah this
is cool so
for me
i'm just an awareness guy as soon as
soon as i get the awareness so
i went in not knowing certain things
just as far as like marketing goes as
far as youtube goes and even as far as
like
bettering your bettering your worst
even that nick peterson
i looked at areas in my life
where i was like you know what
ever so often i'll have some gummy bears
right
and it's that that's my like
that's my thing i'll just like but
that's like my cheat it's like so every
so often somebody will have a glass of
wine they don't think they have an issue
but if it's like it's a pattern that
keeps running you then the pattern
is actually the thing that's taking life
away from you so gummy bears for me it
energetically pulls me at sometimes
so after i left not trying to better my
best
but truly
one percent better in that area
i came across some gummy bears but in a
moment where i really really really
wanted them
and i said i'm powerfully choosing
not to have any gummy bears and it
wasn't not to have it and like force
myself
i powerfully chose and what i didn't
realize is i planted the seed to make
this choice and like you said but here's
the byproduct
it developed
it developed
my level of focus in another area it's
kind of like um mr miyagi with uh with
karate kid he was like wax on wax off he
thought he was doing this but it was
working out this other he was actually
learning how to fight through cleaning
so i
developed the discipline
to say
no and no can actually be really
powerful when you when
when you're not being weak about it
you're actually being powerful about it
i said no i'm powerfully choosing not to
have the gummy bears and then all of a
sudden i was confronted with something
else that typically pulls me in
and i was like
nah no thanks and i didn't feel the pull
that i didn't feel the drive i'm like
wow my discipline is developing because
i needed to start and then i developed
and created and made my old hard my new
easy
and so that's what i got out of this
whole thing and it just keeps going and
now it's like my results are better i
feel more clear i'm getting better sleep
because of the decisions that i made
three days ago
i made my old heart my new easy i love
it dude i love it okay listen before i
let you go the last time i last time i
talked to you you were just about to
leave your old place
and and you did like one last quick tour
and you know
one one last look at the black jesus and
everything else so uh you're in your new
place i don't know how like officially
settled in you are and i'm sure there's
still some other things you're working
on but what is what is the room or the
piece of art or the most inspiring thing
in the new place that gets you going the
whole entire house i'll give you a whole
all right let's see let's see what we
got
all right
so me and my wife live here
um i wouldn't say that this is our dream
house but this is this house is a dream
i'll take you from the back to the front
hold on
we're walking into the front door
we walk in
there's dobby
there's here it's an open floor plane on
the top floor
right here
my this is gonna be my wife's office so
we're building all this here there's
gonna be windows
good friend of mine robin chance did
this painting
so this is what i got my wife for
mother's day
okay this is the top floor
this is the bar here
there's a painting i just painted
there's my wife's painting
got the mask okay
this is the living room where we watch
tv
all this stuff
here's the kitchen
yes that is a double island i'm gonna
take you outside in the backyard
hold on one second
this is our little deck
we got a resort-sized swimming pool
outside
over there is a cascade so we have two
ponds in the backyard we have a natural
well on the property
um
there's our pickleball court basketball
court all that's our land back there
and then we're gonna go inside
oh this is a
little awning
i mean like a little thing that we just
had built right there
hold on one second
okay that's my daughter's high chair
and we got this over here let me take
y'all somewhere
hold on one second i'll take y'all to
our
room this is our room
right here
we got the window here
me and my wife's bedroom
it's the closet
this is my side this is my wife's side
i won't show you my guns this time
however
may not want to come into my house
without my permission
okay
i'll show you the best part hold on
there's my ashy toes
so my office
has just gotten built so there's no
furniture in it but i
just we're getting everything done this
is where my podcast is going to be
nice
my dad my office desk is going to be
there it's going to be a nice painting
there
and this is going to be my man
man den right here
and
the out there is going to be outdoor
patio
this is the restroom
we're almost done
this is our ceremony room so it's like
meditation room
all these kind of things
there's my drums
hey
we have some fun down here
there's all these books
okay and here's my favorite part are you
ready for this
let's go
all right here's my favorite part
so evan when you come to austin
we're gonna go watch a ufc fight in our
theater
nice
yeah we're gonna watch the ufc fight not
theater softest carpet ever
and
we'll get a workout in the morning
in the gym but by the time you get here
the sauna is going to be there the ice
bath's going to be there all this is
being remodeled so it's going to look
like you're coming to tulum
and that's about it for now i love it
man i love it
thanks for giving us a tour it's awesome
now we're just missing some art we got
to see some crazy art on the walls
that's that's yeah it's coming
a lot of a lot of art is coming my
friend robin chance is really
bringing us lots of pieces
and everything but we're still doing
lots of remodeling
but uh
super happy for you that's awesome yeah
and it's really cool because we got this
house
last year
and it's grown
it's grown three million in one year
living in austin is one of the highest
is one of the uh one of the
the fastest growing cities to move in so
even if you're not moving austin
buy you a place here buy a small place
small
and then just let it sit for two years
or airbnb and then watch what happens
i love it dude okay last question you've
done so much to help everybody your
community my community now here too
youtube stay tuned for garen's
upcoming channel
uh if all the people that you've helped
were to hold you in their prayers
tonight
what would you have them pray for
oh that's good
if all of the people that i've impacted
directly and indirectly which is
millions of people
i would have them
pray for me
to develop
the continuous skills
to be an exceptional father
to not only my um
my 20 year old but an exceptional father
to
uh my six month old
and uh
that matters more to me
than
all this stuff outwardly
it it really does and the more and more
i lean into fatherhood and there's a lot
of stuff that i don't know because i you
know when i was 22 i didn't really
didn't know who i was
so
now being 42 and being able to lean in
you know it's uh the dynamics is very
different than my first daughter kylia
and baby soul
and i'd say just pray for just uh
harmony the spirit of harmony inside the
family you know i'm a follower of christ
and i you know i pray every day and and
but i also receive prayers
from
every religious background i do not do
not deny prayer from anyone
um i receive
prayers from all
that i may
become continuously an exceptional
father
and be able to hold
that space
that marries all of my family together
for those who are separate and may they
truly feel
the essence of family because i do have
a picture one day that we're all sitting
at the dinner table
and there's no
there's no none of that negative energy
is like wow
this
this is family
that's what i would love in prayer
i got goose bumps man that's beautiful
yeah mr karen jones in the house
appreciate you man we'll talk to you
soon all right bro take care okay take
care to see my last amazing one-on-one
with garen jones check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there black lives matter's on the
surface but what's underneath
is a cry society's agenda
has been constructed to train people to
be